.
THANK YOU.
ONE OF THE REASONS PARENTS PUT
UP WITH THIS IS ANYONE WHO SAYS
ANYTHING IS INSTANTLY PUNISHED
RATE HE WAS A GIRLS SOCCER COAC
YOU IN VERMONT HE WAS JUST
SUSPENDED FROM HIS JOB WITHOUT
PAY BECAUSE HE COMPLAINED ABOUT
A MALE STUDENT LOOMING AROUND
THE GIRLS LOCKER ROOM.
THEM THE SCHOOL PUNISHED HIS
DAUGHTER, BLAKE ALLEN FOR
SPEAKING ABOUT IT TOO.
BLAKE ALLEN IS ON THE VOLLEYBAL
TEAM.
BLAKE ALLEN AND TRAVIS ALLEN
JOIN US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
TRAVIS, FIRST TO YOU.
DID I MISS STATE WHAT HAPPENED?
YOU COMPLAINED ABOUT A MAN AND
THE LITTLE WOMEN'S LOCKER ROOM
AND YOU ARE PUNISHED?
>> CORRECT FREIGHT I MADE AN
IMMEDIATE SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
THAT REFERRED TO THE MALE
STUDENT IS A MALE AND I WAS
PUNISHED BECAUSE I MISS GENDER
TEMPERED.
>> ILLUSTRATIVE JOB OR YOU WERE
SUSPENDED WITHOUT PAY FROM YOUR
JOB RIGHT.
>> CORRECT, AS THE SOCCER COACH.
>> SO YOU WHERE THE CREEP IN
THIS.
I HAVE TO ASK, DID OTHER
EMPLOYEES TAKE YOU ASIDE AND SA
WE ARE ON YOUR SIDE.
DID ANYONE PROTESTER SUSPENSION?
>> NONE OF THE OTHER SCHOOL
MEMBERS HAVE, BUT THE OTHER
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMPLAINING BY
THE WAY AT THE VERY LEAST.
BLAKE ALLEN, WHAT DID YOU DO
WRONG IN THE EYES OF THE SCHOOL
AND HOW ARE YOU PUNISHED?
>> I WAS IN THE LOCKER ROOM AND
THE STUDENT WALKED IN AND THERE
WAS THE REST OF THE TEAM WAS IN
THERE AND I WAS UNCOMFORTABLE
AND I LEFT AND I TOLD THE SCHOO
AND THEY JUST SHUT ME DOWN AND
SAID THERE WAS NOTHING THEY
COULD DO AND I WAS SUSPENDED
BECAUSE I VOICED MY OPINION THA
A MAN SHOULDN'T BE IN THE
WOMEN'S LOCKER ROOM.
THEN WHEN WE FILED A LAWSUIT,
THEY DROPPED THE SUSPENSION.
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU.
HOW OLD WERE YOU WHEN THIS
HAPPENED?
>> I'M 14, I'M A FRESHMAN
PERKING 14 YEARS OLD AND YOU
COMPLAINED ABOUT A DUDE IN THE
GIRLS LOCKER ROOM, AND YOU GOT
SUSPENDED.
>> HE HAS SPREAD.
>> CAN YOU TELL US THE NAME OF
THE PERSON THAT MADE THAT
DECISION?
>> LEAVE MILLINGTON.
>> AND HOW DID THIS ADULT
COMMUNICATE YOUR SUFFICIENT TO
YOU?
WHAT DID YOU DO WRONG IN THE
VIEW OF THIS ADULT?
>> I THINK THEY WERE MAD THAT I
WAS TELLING PEOPLE HOW I THOUGH
IT WAS WRONG AND THAT MEL
SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO BE WITH
US IN THE LOCKER ROOM.
>> YOU ARE 14 YEARS OLD, TELL U
WHAT YOUR CLASSMATES THOUGHT,
WERE THEY ON YOUR SIDE?
>> A LOT OF MY CLASSMATES WERE
SUPPORTIVE, I THINK MOST PEOPLE
AND THE SCHOOL ARE, THEY ARE
JUST TOO SCARED TO SPEAK UP
BECAUSE THEY SEE ALL THE
BACKLASH I'M GETTING FOR IT.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY WAS I SUSPENDED
.
THANK YOU.
I WAS GOING TO DO RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE CIRCLE AND WRITE A
LETTER OF APOLOGY.
>> TO WHOM?
TO THE DUDE?
>> THE TRANS STUDENT.
>> TO THE BOY WHO WAS IN THE
GIRLS LOCKER ROOM.
>> I SAID I WOULD RATHER HAVE A
FIVE DAY SUSPENSION AND HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I'M NOT SORRY.
>> HOW WILT WAS THE BOY?
>> 14.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
ARE YOU GOING TO CONTINUE AT TH
SCHOOL?
>> YEAH, FOR NOW.
>> IT IS SO UNBELIEVABLE.
ONLY WHEN PEOPLE LIKE YOU TAKE
THE LUMPS, STAND UP AND TELL TH
TRUTH, JUST BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS
LIKE THE RIGHT TO CHANGE WITHOU
SOME GUY STARING AT YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
WILLING TO TALK ON THE SHOW.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING US.
>> WE WANT TO GO TO TYSON LANG
HOFFER.
TYSON, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHAT IS THE CASE THAT YOU'RE
MAKING ON BEHALF OF THESE TWO.
TO GET THIS SCHOOL DISTRICT,
THEY RETALIATED AGAINST BOTH
BLAKE AND TRAVIS FOR SIMPLY
STATING THEIR VIEWS.
IN FIRST AMENDMENT RETALIATION
IS A PROHIBITED BY THE
CONSTITUTION.
THAT'S VERY CLEAR.
THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT RETALIATE
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS WERE SIMPLY
SHARING THEIR VIEWS.
THE CRAZY THING IS THAT BLAKE
UNDERSTANDS THIS ISSUE PERIGEE
DOESN'T NEED TO BE REEDUCATED.
MEALS ARE MALES AND FEMALES OUR
FEMALES.
LAKE SHOULDN'T BE FORCED TO
CHANGE IN FRONT OF A MALE OR
WATCH A MALE CHANGE, BUT THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO FORCE HE
TO DO.
THEY WANT TO PUNISH ANYBODY THA
HAS A DIFFERENT POINT.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT THEY
CARED ABOUT GIRLS TO.
13 -YEAR-OLD GIRLS DON'T HAVE A
RIGHT TO GET DRESSED WITHOUT A
BOY WATCHING?
I'M HARDLY A FEMINIST, BUT WHER
ARE ALL THE FEMINIST GROUPS?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
THAT'S A REALLY SAD THING.
WHEN A FATHER COMES AND SAYS HEY
, WHO IS STANDING UP FOR MY
DAUGHTER, HE GETS PUNISHED AND
LOSES HIS JOB, HE IS SUSPENDED
WITHOUT PAY FOR SIMPLY SAYING
WHAT ABOUT MY DAUGHTER?
TO GET THIS AD THING IS ALL THE
OTHER FATHERS THAT DIDN'T DO
THAT.
THEY WERE COWERING LIKE THE
COWARDS THEY ARE IN THEIR HOME
AND LETTING THIS HAPPEN TO THEI
GIRLS WITHOUT FIGHTING BACK
GREAT I HOPE THEY FE